hi I'm Erik Bosse the stranger things
season 3 hits the poor folks of Hawkins
Indiana with a third round of bloody
terror that only the 1980s knew how to
deliver and like the absorbent monster
of this season these episodes are a
gooey amalgam of eighties references an
omelet of Easter eggs made of people I'm
gonna break down all the interesting
details that were easy to overlook not
just all the vintage eighties stuff
that's on every shelf but like the
really subtle production details that no
one ever talks about it's morning in
case you haven't seen the new season yet
ok here we go
chapter 1 titled Susie do you copy takes
place in June 1984 a lab in Russia with
a similar interdimensional experiment
going on as we saw in Hawkins lab
scientists doing in season 1 to Soviet
scientists turn Keys simultaneously to
begin the test a nod to the opening
scene of wargames suggesting that this
device is as potentially globally
catastrophic as nuclear war and perhaps
serving the same kind of purpose to the
rival superpowers this scene introduces
us to these scientists Alexei as well as
the super strong almost inhuman assassin
Gregory who is clearly modeled on the
terminator Schwarzenegger even gets a
shout out later on this season
which will be your later to Hawkins
where L is making out with Mike wheeler
in our bedroom there's some cassette
tapes visible including Corey Hart's boy
in the box so what they're listening to
here in Bryan Adams reckless you'll
notice that L is still wearing that blue
bracelet she started wearing that last
season after becoming hoppers adopted
daughter before her he wore that
bracelet
after fascinating it from a hair tie of
his daughter when it passed away mm-hmm
meanwhile Hopper watches an episode of
magnum p.i the Tom Selleck detective
show that hopper clearly fancies himself
after later this season a carnie will
tell him Mike will Lucas a max sneak
into an early screening of George
Romero's Day of the Dead this movie
zombie outbreak reflects the mind flares
infection upon the Hawkins residence and
honor the dead was set primarily in a
shopping mall just like this season's
final act they go through the back door
of scoops ahoy the ice cream shop where
Steve Harrington and the newcomer Robin
work and they're working in form does
look a bit like this same kind of sailor
outfit worn by the Stay Puft Marshmallow
Man of ghostbusters
Nancy Donovan wake up late and on the
walls of Jonathan's room Zara posters
for REM and the
dead with the evil that being another
shout-out to influential 80s horror
later you'll see the inky vein pattern
on Billy's body it's actually similar to
the look of the Deadites of Evil Dead
and when Jonathan puts on his pants he
falls over just like Marty McFly does
and Back to the Future when putting on
his pants Dustin returns home from
science camp radio enos buds this is
gold leader returning to base do you
copy over of course a nod to the gold
squadron of Star Wars and then when they
surprised them he accidentally sprays
Lucas with this hair spray this is the
exact Farrah Fawcett hairspray that
Steve recommended he used last season
Justin shows off its new inventions
including an electric hammer that he
calls the slammer which is very similar
to the device invented by Randall
Peltzer in gremlins and of course Dustin
aids his radio antennae cerebro from the
x-men comics that's the device Professor
X uses to locate fellow mutants
essentially what Dustin says with his
fellow super nerd Suzy justin described
suzy repeatedly as phoebe cates
but hotter Phoebe Cates was the actress
from the famous best times at ridgemont
high pool scene and she later cameos as
a standee at the video rental store in
the final episode at the pool Billy
struts past the Hawkins mom's including
Karen wheeler who reads a new Joanna
Lindley romance novel this season Billy
calls out to a kid to tell him to stop
running and calls him lard-ass not to
the other major stranger things
influencers stand by me which in that
movie adapted Stephen King's other story
The Revenge of lard-ass hogan hopper
seeks advice from Joyce at the general
store and on the nearby shelf is a Jack
O'Lantern bucket which we know for a
flashback is something that Bob inquired
about signaling his lingering memory
coming between her and hopper in the
earlier part of the season popper jokes
about killing Mike saying I'm Chief of
Police are you covered hopper wasn't
horse modeled partly on chief Brody and
jaws who spoke a similar line I can do
anything I'm the chief of police in
later hopper also drunk on wine quotes
this line exactly do anything I want
Chief of Police at the newspaper office
Nancy takes a message from Doris
Driscoll about rats eating her
fertilizer now this is a nod to the
invasion of the body snatchers a huge
influence on this season's story which
featured a protagonist by the name of
Elizabeth Driscoll and like the season
evasion The Body Snatchers features a
town of people overtaken by a hive mind
which brings us to chapter 2 the mall
rats the title referencing the term for
a tease kids who spent all their time in
malls in the literal rats swarming to
the steel plant is to be turned into goo
or the mind flayer the main villain from
season two still alive even more threat
notice that the mine player uses a
tendril that attaches to people's faces
just like how the face hugger from the
xenomorph attaches to hosts in the Alien
franchise a poster for John Carpenter's
The Thing is spotted in the wheelers
basement the thing was another huge
influence on season 3 with the whole
body horror of human and animal flesh
melting into indistinguishable ghoul
monsters and speaking that goo when
Nancy and Jonathan head off to
investigate the rats he says for the old
lady is nuts
and your story blows up in her face and
Tom fires us just a little foreshadowing
of this story's literal explosive turns
later on whether it's rats or fireworks
or Russian portal devices destined
adorably reconnects with this mother
Steve Harrington at scripts of Hawaii
and in the background you can see two
elderly women swapping each other's ice
creams just like Max and eleven do later
this episode time travel confirmed
destined tell Steve about intercepting
the Russian transmission saying it means
Steve we could be heroes he's kind of
more shadowing the final scene of the
season in which Peter Gabriel's cover of
Bowie's heroes plays which was calling
back the time the track was sampled in
season 1 with will buyers fake death
later when Erica abuses the sample
policy the cash register reads zero to a
nod to this being episode 2 of the
season Ella max hang out and Max oozes
the madrid brand of skateboard popular
80's brand that Marty McFly used him
back to the future and a Max's bedroom
there's a poster for the 60s surf movie
the endless summer and a board game
can't stop on the Shelf inside mrs.
Driscoll says there's a cat clock on the
wall which is exactly like one of the
many clocks and Doc Brown's workshop in
the opening shot of Back to the Future
later when her caged rat explodes into
goo it oozes to the ground and slashes
away siding up the way the mind flayer
causes this flesh to move
and it's actually similar to the
movement of the alien amoeba creature of
the blob hopper meets with Mayor Larry
Klein played by Cary Elwes of The
Princess Bride and if Hopper is chief
Brody from Jaws mayor Larry Klein is
mayor Larry Vaughn of Amity Island in
Jaws a spineless politician who
knowingly endangered the town on the 4th
of July for short-term political and
economic gain joy stands up hoppers
dinner date while researching
electromagnetism with the boys old
science teacher mr. Clerk he listens to
Weird Al's parody song my Bellona while
working on his town miniature set just
like the one in the opening shot of
Beetlejuice actually you look real
closely there is a tiny Beetlejuice
grade that they snuck in there Steve
Harrington makes his one big
contribution to robbing and Dustin's
Russian decoding by recognizing the
music from the Indiana flyer hoarse
Daisy bell like a bicycle built for two
which is the famous song that the how
9000 things when he's shutting down and
2001 a Space Odyssey moving on to
chapter 3 the case of the missing light
guard which opens with Max and L aw
Glenn / Karate Kid Ralph Macchio and
Tiger Beat Magazine later you'll notice
Lucas
appears an outfit seemingly inspired by
the Karate Kid kids got moves Ellie uses
her powers to spy on the boys which ends
with Lucas ripping one which might
remind you of the amazing dusted parted
song in season 1 does the body okay very
well Justin and Steve scope out the mall
for evil Russians okay I don't know what
an evil Russian looks like tall blond
not smiling
Dustin is referencing the high von Drago
trope from the then-upcoming rocky 4
with Drago bean another Soviet killer
that Gregory was probably based on it'll
uses her powers to seek out the missing
lifeguard Heather finding her in an ice
tub which then plunges Heather into this
black depth region similar to Jordan
peels sunken place visuals and get out
whole-step Bertie doubles of Billy
Heather and later other townspeople
while their shoe soles are in the mind
flayer sunken place is very Jordan
Pelion as is the moment flayed Billy and
Heather attack Heather's parents which
evokes that shot of Elizabeth moss and
us and earlier in the scene I liked a
little clue that reflects how everything
isn't quite right with Billy notice his
shirt it's half tucked from played Billy
trying to come off as a nice kid but
also half untucked as Billy would
probably normally keep it also in this
episode hopper first confronts Gregory
an admission chief Brody hopper
is also an adaptation of Indiana Jones
as past season silhouettes of him and
his hats have shown we get another
really cool shadow shot here with the
gun similar to the many iconic Indy
shadow shots now a number of you are
asking about Mike's interesting line to
will in this episode so my fault you
don't like girls now I guess you could
interpret this to draw some conclusions
about will buyers sexuality but I don't
know it doesn't really seem to be played
that way at least in the moment it kind
of seems more like to me that will might
just feel pressure for still feeling
like a child while his friends are
chasing girls and you might just have
different interests or he's not at that
point in this maturity yet because as we
see after this will goes off to destroy
his old castle buyers clubhouse which is
a critical growing point for the
character foreshadowing his departure
from Hawkins with really no home for him
to go back to by doing this he kind of
reflects that old adage of time to put
away childish things which offer CS
Lewis later rephrase to add including
the fear of childishness so hopefully we
can look at this as will growing up a
little but still his inner creativity
living on but in this season wills
purpose from here forward is mostly just
to sense the mind flayers presence with
his will tingle on the back of his neck
and he tells Mike and Lucas he's back
we'll just kind of like stranger things
threes version of Carol Ann's famous
line and poltergeist
[Music]
and some said that the shot of L and Max
could be a nod to the Grady twins of the
shining with maybe Georgie sail a
raincoat from its Navy similarity isn't
always homage only when I say this
moving on to chapter 4 the sauna test a
nod to the kids plan to trap blade Billy
in the sauna room at the pool knowing
that the mind flayer hates heat and this
test parallels the famous test in the
thing which Macready tests everyone
blood to see which is actually the gooey
evil monster which in that movie also
hates heat l and max look at comic books
when a woman 326 in green lantern 185
and Dustin makes the meta observation
that Steve has never actually won up
this fight reminding us that he got his
ass beat by Jonathan the season 1 and
Billy in season 2 but he does finally an
episode 5 of the season win a fight but
as in past seasons that pretty boy face
does get bloodied and bruised up it's
kind of like favorite interestings
tradition now in addition to callbacks
of pop-culture references stranger
things it's also really great with
subtle visual details and camera
movement watch closely the scene in
which Slade Tom the editor fires Nancy
and Jonathan roars at Nancy and kicks
his chair mundi does the camera tilts
askew and it stays at the same tilted
angle on Tom and on Nancy and Jonathan
for the rest of the scene so like
Billy's half untucked shirt and Tom's
bandage and sweat here this is another
visual detail reflecting the eight
rightness of the scene hopper knocks
Mary clients face askew finally kicking
in the gear this season
simultaneously reusing little details
that he must have gathered when we
thought he was drunk like the spotting
of Gregory leaving Klein's office and
Klein's a cigar cutter I also like how
as Hopper interrogate spline he
initially grabs Klein's nameplate a
threat to show that he's not afraid to
choke the truth out of him Robin gets
the malls blueprints and they devise a
plan to use the air ducts which Erica
later crawls through sand she's small
enough a nod to the famous air duct
scenes of alien and die hard now the
others conduct the sauna test on flayed
Billy who smashes through the window
glass at max in season two dr.
Montgomery said that the duffer's told
him to research Jack Nicholson in the
shining for inspiration and here now
Billy goes full here's Johnny dropping
f-bombs just like Jack did at Windy in
the earlier scene
I'm not gonna hurt you I'm just gonna
bash your brains I'm gonna bash right in
and speaking of kubrick references after
L fans off laid Billy the episode ends
with the mind flayer hive mind and the
song will meet again most famous is the
music that played over Kubrick's closing
mushroom cloud montage and dr.
Strangelove next up there's chapter five
the flayed hopper and Joyce find alexei
whom hopper calls Smirnoff a nod to
Yakov Smirnoff the Soviet porn American
comedian who was super popular in the
80s
grigory later shoots him and calls him a
traitor for embracing American culture
similarly the KGB weren't very big fans
of Yakov Smirnoff's
defection and Soviet bashing Alexey look
also resembles Matthew Reese's character
and the Americans on FX his character
was a Soviet sleeper cell spy disguising
himself as American in the 80s and like
Alexey he also came to love American
culture the convertible that they later
steal is the vanity plate Todd father
with his douche Todd seeing himself as
The Godfather justin radios to the
others from the subterranean russian
base as dustin notes later this is a Red
Dawn scenario that's the 80s film in
which the Soviet Union invades the US
and a group of kids in a western town
fight back another 80s kids fight back
movie The Goonies gets another stranger
things reference when Dustin says Holy
Mother of God
a nod to one of the final lines from The
Goonies as this group walks that endless
hall Dustin suggested the green fluid
they found could be promethium which
Robin cites is a nod to the cyborg DC
Comics in which promethium was a
substance that Victor stones father used
for his Bionic and cybernetic components
the conspiracy theorist Murray Baumann
returns from season 2 he helps him
translate for Alexei and the kids go to
see mrs. Driscoll in hawkins Memorial
Hospital whose h MH logo looks exactly
like the logo from Haddonfield Memorial
Hospital from the Halloween movies slate
editor Tom shows up again and note that
just like flayed Billy his shirt is half
tucked
flayed Tom and also flayed Bruce Jake
Busey get beaten and they melt in a goo
oozing into aid not yet
final form version the mind player
another reference to how the monster
from the thing used carcasses to fuse
together into an unspeakably huge
monster which brings us to chapter 6 e
pluribus unum its title referring to the
United States motto meaning out of many
one used ironically here to reflect the
Soviet subversion of the US city also of
course the way the many Flay two come
together to make one giant monster in
the final scene so they defeat mind
flayer jr. and it's seeps into the sewer
even behind pieces of broken bone at the
great choice and hopper learned from
Alexian Murray that the Russians were
conducting similar interdimensional
experiments that the Americans were in
Hawkins and are now using the facility
under the star Court mall for which the
land was sold to them by Mayor Cline to
shipped in equipment for the lab where
the old gateway was so if this tech is
an analogy for the nuclear arms race
between the US and the USSR in the 80s
this would kind of be like if a nuclear
leak disaster happened in America was
covered up and then later Russians snuck
in to continue weapons research on that
property but it's on someone else's soil
alexey uses a straw and fast-food
wrappers to demonstrate what does the
call back to mr. clark using the analogy
of the flea in the acrobat to explain
the upside down in season one meanwhile
erica finds a large cage in the facility
how big did you say that demo google was
why this except the big reveal in the
seasons post-credit scene
the return of the demagogue on or maybe
a Dimmick organ with the russians having
one that they apparently feed prisoners
to el connects with billy and learns
about his past abuse that she later uses
to get Billy to help her defeat the mind
flayer monster in the final episode but
in the scene billy sits frozen on his
bed with this intense stare it could be
another parallel between Billy and Jack
Torrence from The Shining and behind
them on his bedroom wall there's a
poster for the Metallica album kill them
all definitely reflection the mind
flayers mindset that he reveals to l on
her way back out of this connection
hopper and joyce call a number given to
them by dr. sam owens last season that
was Paul Reiser's government scientist
he actually shows up at the end of the
season presumably to keep a lid on
everything and hopper gives the contact
Murray's phone number six with six six
to five eighty three one three eight if
you actually call that number you get an
interesting away message recording
Joyce Joyce thank you for calling I've
been trying to reach you I have enough
this perhaps to suggest that wherever
Joyce took will and L at the end of the
season the drama with the mind flare the
upside-down could have followed them and
that's why Joyce is reaching out for
help or maybe Marie has information that
Hopper could still be alive since the
Russians are keeping an unknown American
in a holding cell that we saw on the
post-credits scene the residents holding
Stephen Robin interrogating them with
truth serum find that Dustin and Erica
have returned burning holes through the
levels with that green substance similar
to the Xenomorphs acidic blood burning
holes through layer after layer in the
Nostromo an alien moving on to chapter 7
the bite which opens at mayor Klein's
carnival in a speech she says she's
found this also foreshadows the final
battle with the mine flare in which the
kids used Satan's baby m-80s on it Holly
wheeler sees that the trees down below
are moving a nod to Spielberg shot in
lost world drastic park some other
drastic park shots show up when the kids
are hiding from the monster in the mall
behind counters similar to the kids in
Jurassic Park in the kitchen they gear
up to fight the monster in the cabin
with the camera circling their huddle
just like the shot of Nancy and Jonathan
bracing to fight the demagogue in in the
buyer's home in season 1 now their
battle here evokes Evil Dead in Evil
Dead 2 with Jonathan hacking away with
an axe just like we saw in the Evil Dead
and when a piece of the monster gets cut
off it crawls away just like ashes evil
hand does and I couldn't help it to see
a parallel with the movie The Cabin in
the woods with one group of characters
fighting through their lives in a cabin
up on the surface
another group of characters down below
driving trams in a secret underground
facility just in America hides Stephen
Robin and a screening of Back to the
Future with Alan Silvestri's famous
score humorously playing alongside the
drama that these kids are going through
[Music]
please Mike and the radio going dead on
Dustin here is played it just like the
time machine battery dying on Marty
right at the most climactic moment they
patch up Elle's wound at a grocery store
where Lukas passes a bunch of old school
cereal like pac-man cereal mr. t cereal
Rainbow Brite GI Joe action stars and
ghostbusters cereal and as L goes back
under beneath her beloved Eggo waffles
Lucas sips on some new coke comparing it
to John Carpenter's The Thing which is a
better regarded remake from a 1951 film
and this is just a little ironic to us
now considering the thing was remade
again as a prequel in 2011 it was pretty
bad also playing at the cinema or the
movies Darrel was about a super smart
kid robot on the run from government
scientists kind of like 11 was this he's
one there's also Return to Oz which is a
live-action sequel to The Wizard of Oz
about Dorothy returning after escaping
electric shock treatment time that ELLs
mom underwent
there's also cocoon which is about the
retirement home residents to become
rejuvenated through an alien life force
in a swimming pool Flesch that was at
Chevy Chase comedy and the stuffs about
a creamy addictive food that was
revealed to be a parasite controlling
people's minds kinda mind flayers doing
this season robbing Steve Eric and
Dustin escape Russian guards by sliding
down the space between escalator
railings is a shot lifted directly from
Dawn of the Dead I'll actually have some
fun at the carnival he wins a dart
throwing booth prize and if you look
closely among those prizes among them
are some stuffed gizmos from gremlins
hopper fights Grigory and the other
Russian guards in the funhouse the
setting is really kind of a troupe in a
lot of movies and they realized that
elves bite from the mind flayer left a
piece of it and plant it in her leg
bringing us to the final episode chapter
8 the Battle of star courts and which
they were haphazardly extracted it
evokes the classic chestburster scene
from alien the little creature trying to
scamper away after here
hopper stomp says so with everyone now
reunited they split up into groups again
but Dustin McNamee Nancy's group
Griswold family a nod to the national
lampoon's vacation movies hopper shoots
the Russians downstairs doing
I'm improvising this is another suit
first figure it out as you go kind of
move that hopper shares with the great
dr. Jones I'm going after that truck oh
maybe this upside go
and of course disguising himself as
enemy soldiers is a different Harrison
Ford character move Han Solo
when they dressed up as stormtroopers in
Star Wars so to reach the key they have
to enter slinks constant which in
quantum physics is the constant for
electromagnetic action relating the
energy carried by a photon to its
frequency but they don't remember it
perfectly so Dustin has to call his
actually existing girlfriend Suzy she's
reading the book a wizard of Earthsea
that was the first of the fantasy
Earthsea novel series and she makes
Dustin duet with her the neverending
story theme song before telling the
right number so while joy struggles to
turn both keys to turn off the device
hopper has his final fistfight with
Gregory by the machines whirring blades
eventually throws Gregory into the
blades chopping them up this is exactly
like Indiana Jones fighting the Nazi
brute in the plane propeller blades and
Raiders of the Lost Ark and if you think
about it and the way Gregory is done in
by the machine that Alexi the man he
killed helped build so Joyce is able to
shut off the machine causing an
explosion that evaporates a bunch of
scientists and hopper appears to die in
this blast though we never see his body
evaporate Joyce covers her eyes and
briefly the platform that he was
standing on appears empty giving more
evidence to his survival actually check
out my post credit scene breakdown for
more information on that so three months
later a news report dismisses the events
as a chemical leak chalks it up to
satanic rituals is the nod to the
satanic panic trend of the 1980s
unfortunately a lot of kids who play D&D
were thought to be devil worshipers
Steve and Robin applied for a job at the
video rental store from Keith that was
the arcade employee from season 2 and L
moves away with Joyce and wil she reads
hoppers letter as Peter Gabriel's cover
of Bowie's heroes plays again check out
my post credits scene breakdown for why
the final words of hoppers letter and
this music could both be clues for
hoppers survival so do you think hopper
is still alive and where do you think
stranger things fourth season could go
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow me on Instagram and Twitter I
da Voss and subscribe to new rockstars
to break downs and theories on
everything you love thanks for joining
me in oh my god how do I get chocolate
on the back of my neck
[Music]